after the farmer and the pie Jane and it
get involved in this forward contract a
few questions start to pop up in each of
their minds the main one is what if the
other party isn't able to uphold then
their end of the contract and this is
called counterparty risk counterparty
risk which is essentially the
counterparty to the farmer is the PI
store and the counterparty to the PI
chain is the farmer and it's the risk
that the other party won't be able to
uphold their end of the contract the
other thing that starts to worry either
one of these is what if they start to
have second thoughts about this forward
contract that they entered into would
they be able to maybe sell their
obligation to someone else so is there
any way to trade to trade the contract
and then there's another issue that even
if you were to trade the contract how do
we know that the other party to the
whoever you might want to trade with
would be cool with a million pounds or
two hundred thousand dollars maybe they
would want to deal with a smaller
quantity maybe they would only want a
thousand pounds or $100,000 worth of
apples so the local the local brain
comes up with an idea he's like why
don't we standardize these forward
contracts why don't I just create a
bunch of contracts
whenever someone wants to enter into one
of these forward contracts but I
standardized them and I say that it is a
thousand instead of having a million
apples I do a small enough increment so
I say a thousand pounds of apples apples
for delivery for delivery on let's say
November on November 15th and every one
of these contracts say the same thing a
thousand pounds of apples for delivery
on 1115 and this guy he's also the
richest guy in town he's already been
running a stock exchange and so to to
help alleviate the counterparty risk
fear he also says that I'm going to
guarantee I will guarantee any of these
any of these contracts so essentially
he's taking on all of the counterparty
risk to make people more comfortable
with trading
so all of a sudden what happens is is
that now these guys don't have to do a
one-off contract they don't have to do
this one-off forward contract there are
these standardized contracts that this
exchange can now trade and what happens
is is that smaller farmers so small let
me do this in a different color
you have farmers farmer a farmer B
farmer B can now can now transact with
I should say I guess we could call it
customer customer C and customer
customer D where they could agree to
have a fixed price but they could do
smaller increments more granular
increments and if any of them want to
get out of it they can by selling their
contract to another person on the
exchange and these more standardized
forward contracts they're still
essentially the same thing they're just
standardized their agreements to
transact at a future date give a certain
amount of money for a certain amount of
something else it could be a security it
could be apples these things these
standardized forward contracts these are
called these are called futures where
they're standardized and they are traded
on an exchange